so there's this funny story floating
around about how Trump has been caught
on an audio recording uh snatching the
phone from a reporter on a plane
recently and saying I don't want to talk
about I don't like your questions I
don't want to talk about essentially the
recent arrest you know what what to me
is really the story is that every time
there's a sort of outlandish or
difficult to believe story about Trump
According to some like for example when
Cassidy Hutchinson testified under oath
that Trump lunged at a secret service
agent and Trump said does that sound
like something I would do come on I
would never do that sort of thing and
then the right Wingers come out and say
Obviously these stories are made up and
we ask ourselves does this sound like
Trump is this the type of thing Trump is
known for doing and of course the answer
is yes and then now we just get yet
another story this time with an audio
recording that says Trump trump does
lunge at people and snap at people all
the time